one of the biggest moments of this
current presidency occurred this week
with Supreme Court Justice Anthony
Kennedy announcing that he is retiring
from the court for many conservatives
Supreme Court nominations were the
single most important issue of the last
election the reason they voted and
they'll be watching this very closely
who are the frontrunner to replace
Justice Kennedy and what do we know
about them joining us now is someone who
knows the answer is Leonard Leo is an
outside adviser to the President on
judicial nominations and he joins us to
learn thank you very much for coming on
so we're hearing a number of names
batted around Amy Barrett is at the top
of every list I've read in the last two
days tell me what do you what do we know
about Amy Barrett Amy Barrett's a judge
on the Seventh Circuit out there in the
Midwest Chicago
she's from Indiana very distinguished
law professor from Notre Dame Law School
clerk for Antonin Scalia one of the most
articulate and intelligent originalist
s-- in the country a very talented woman
Brett Kavanaugh Brett Kavanaugh is a
very respected judge here in Washington
DC on the US Court of Appeals he's been
on that court for over a decade he's
respected on all sides of the political
spectrum as one of the best lawyers in
the country spent a lot of time in
Washington serving in government arguing
before the Supreme Court he's written a
lot of opinions very deep believer and
the idea that if you want to protect
freedom and human dignity you have to
preserve the structural limits on
government power and our Constitution a
lot like Neil Gorsuch Tucker so if
you're following this at home who else
should you be looking up on Wikipedia
right now well look the president came
up with this great idea one of the most
transparent things we've ever seen in
judicial Selection which is to put out a
list of all the people from which he'd
pick their 25 on there which an awful
lot of people but you should be of
certainly looking at people like Brett
Kavanaugh and Amy Barrett Tom Hardiman
who's someone who the president
interviewed last time he's a judge out
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania ray Catholic
who's a judge out in Michigan there are
a couple of other very
English women on the list Joan Larson
who's out from Michigan and Allison Hyde
who's from Colorado all court of appeals
judges all people who really want to
interpret the laws it's written and who
understand that the court has a duty to
to enforce the limits on government
power and and to interpret the
Constitution according to its text and
original meaning they really believe in
the rule of law and it's a tremendous
opportunity for the president to to pick
another justice like Neal Gore said she
was extraordinarily well-qualified
very courageous and independent and who
wants to interpret the Constitution the
way the framers meant it to be can
Democrats stop this is can you imagine
this scenario where they could I think
if the president has a process like he
had the first time engages and lots of
advice and consent picks a great nominee
like Neal Gorsuch if he uses the Gorsuch
model I think it's impossible for the
Democrats to really stop them can you
imagine I think gorse has got a couple
Democratic votes can you imagine that
happening this time okay thank you so
much III think so Tucker I mean again if
you pick someone who's extraordinary and
someone who really does just believe in
interpreting the laws it's written
that's what Garner's widespread public
support and I think it's particularly
hard in an election year like this one
for moderate Democrats to resist a
nominee who's who's so talented and
who's so committed to being a fair
arbiter in court I think you're probably
right
Leonard leo thank you very much for that
I know you're right the center of this
process so it's nice to talk to you good
to talk to you Tucker thanks thank you